hay mucho tiempo para festejar porque ya
se viene el partido de vuelta contra el
manchester city- podemos esperarnos un
resultado como el que ya se dio contra
el pci en la en el octavo de final si la
verdad es la llama más interesante
evidentemente porque si bien el equipo
de guardiola dominó casi todas las fases
del juego en el partido de ida al final
el resultado son 43 y esto de lo que
habla es que tal como lo decía antes
estos jugadores del real madrid tienen
esa jerarquía que se necesita a la hora
de tomar decisiones acertadas durante
momentos del partido en los que las
dificultades o la presión por un
resultado digamos que empiezan a premiar
entonces yo creo que este partido de
vuelta en el bernabéu va a ser muy
interesante porque también empezamos a
hablar de la jerarquía de lo que
representa para un equipo como el real
madrid o una competencia como la
champions league creo que va a ser un
partido muy interesante un partido en el
que es muy difícil dar el pronóstico
y luego tenemos que basar a la otra
llave y evidentemente a la liverpool
y villarreal un villarreal que hizo una
temporada más que digna y en cabeza de
unai emery
evidentemente encontró unas maneras de
competir de manera muy interesante ya
superó por ejemplo a la juve y el bayern
múnich dos de los favoritos en esta
temporada sin embargo sí creo que lo que
ha hecho club en materia ofensiva es muy
difícil de controlar sobre todo pues por
la calidad de jugadores tanto colectivo
como individual así que evidentemente
creería que ésta ya está un poco más
cerrada pero creo que el ambiente
también en villarreal va a ser muy
interesante en el estadio de la cerámica
un equipo que además ha querido en un
proyecto muy interesante así que lo que
nos esperan esta semana otros dos
grandes partidos en esta semis de la
champions